selon direct avec françois-xavier
bellamy et des questions ne vont pas
manquer
radio classique l'invité de guillaume
durand avec le figaro il ya évidemment
les questions de fond évoqué par
guillaume tabard appui à des questions
qui sont au fond les épiphénomènes où
les accidents de campagne est ce que
vous considérez que le passé de sciences
pour de mal à l'oiseau est un problème
militantisme pendant quelque temps at
elle dit et elle ne se souvient plus
exactement d'avoir participé donc à un
groupuscule ou à une liste d'extrême
droite lors d'élections assurances pause
c'était un problème ou pas je vous
remercie pour votre invitation
je me permet de rebondir sur ce que
vient dire guillaume tabard à l'instant
qui je crois est très important beaucoup
a relevé
on va y revenir bien sûr mais beaucoup
plus important que que que cette étrange
oubli de demain oiseaux il ya
effectivement l'absence totale de
transparence sur la ligne sur la vision
sur le projet que porte la liste dans
marche
aujourd'hui les électeurs sont invités à
se prononcer alors qu'ils ne savent pas
du tout ni quels sont les alliés de
madame nozuka avec qui elle va siéger au
parlement européen demain ni non plus
pour défendre quelles mesures on a
effectivement une campagne européenne
qui est volontairement tué par le
président de la république et par sa
majorité
à partir de cette absence totale de
transparence sur le cap et sur le fond
nous ça fait trois mois qu'on fait
campagne avec 75 proposition avec un
projet très clair pour pouvoir offrir
aux français l'occasion d'un vrai choix
et je crois que c'est très grave qu'on
en arrive effectivement à cette
situation on a une campagne paralysé
s'est arrêté là bas c'est moi d'insister
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de commentaires
après ce matin est ce que vous
considérez c'est un épiphénomène
ce que je crois c'est que il faudrait
montrer un peu plus d'humilité quand on
a effectivement ce ses expériences
passées je crois que chacun a pu avoir
son tong itinéraire est sa trajectoire
d'abord il faudrait pouvoir l'assumer de
manière plus transparente et je regrette
de découvrir quand même loiseau a tenté
de nier l'évidence jusqu'à ce qu'elle
soit mise devant les faits et surtout
comment mettre en scène de façon
perpétuelle cette espèce de discours
moralisateur qui voudraient opposer d'un
côté les progressistes populiste quand
soi-même justement on a eu ce type
d'engagement dans sa jeunesse
je lui en serai pas le leur reproche je
crois que chacun peut avoir son
itinéraire mais ça ça oblige à un peu
d'humilité et un peu de simplicité vous
savez dans les campagnes où avaient été
attaqués vous même confirmant les
positions personnelles
à propos de l'avortement bain et tous
les coups sont permis donc il faut
s'aguerrir excusé a l'impression d'être
à nommer aguerris parce qu'on vous dit
pas comme un catho traditionalistes
marche arrière toute
non et tout ça est totalement ridicule
en a eu l'occasion de m'exprimer de très
nombreuses fois sur tout ce par quoi on
a tenté de m'en faire mais et je crois
que le débat européen mérite mieux et
pour ma part je n'emploierai pas le même
type de de stratégie à l'égard de nos
concurrents
donc pourquoi est ce qu'on ne peut pas
en venir au fond pourquoi est ce qu'on
ne va parler on est devant une élection
européenne sans doute la plus importante
depuis les débuts de l'aventuré du
projet européen est devant une élection
européenne qui va sans doute décider de
pour une grande part de notre avenir en
france et en europe
et je crois que effectivement ce débat
mériterait mieux que que dès que dès que
d'aider les petits noms d'oiseaux qui ne
grandissent personnes voilà donc ce
débat je vous avez apprécié enveloppé
dans la république vous l'avez vu taylor
l'a confisquée au profit justement de sa
conférence de presse et la sortie de la
crise et puis il ya donc un slogan que
qui va être dévoilée ce soir alors
j'aurai une petite idée
refonder l'europe et à rétablir la
france est ce que c'est le bon second
d'ailleurs qui va être dévoilé à caen ça
dit tout de ce qu'on veut faire au fond
nous notre travail c'est ce slogan vous
êtes bien informé
refonder l'europe rétablir la france
refonder l'europe parce qu'on a besoin
de repenser en profondeur le projet
européen qui s'est enlisé dans une forme
de naïveté qui fait notre impuissance
aujourd'hui dans la mondialisation
sur le plan économique et commercial
face au défi migratoire face à la crise
écologique il faut repenser la manière
dont l'europe se construit pour qu'elle
soit vraiment au service de notre
renforcement dans la mondialisation et
et nous ne faisons pas de l'europe une
idéologie nous sommes là d'abord pour
faire en sorte que l'europe soit au
service de chacun des états qui la
constituent au service de la france pour
ce qui nous concerne parce que il faut
aussi sortir de la naïveté française en
europe il faut sur la question de la
politique agricole commune par exemple
que le gouvernement a laissé se
détricoter il faut sur les questions
qui touche au rayonnement de la france
en europe il faut aussi que nous
puissions faire en sorte que la france
soit de nouveau audible et crédible
desquels on peut reconstruire mais
comment puisque vous savez que ceux qui
sont anti européens ou d'une certaine
manière hostile la façon dont fonctionne
alors d'aujourd'hui je pense à la france
oui vous rassemblez nationale au fond
l'ordre ont discours c'est de dire tous
décident à berlin dans un entretien au
point lamassoure qui n'est pas du tout
sur cette ligne là qui a été ministre
pendant longtemps pour le de valéry
giscard d'estaing et qui appartient donc
au ppe considère effectivement qu'il ya
beaucoup de décisions comme par exemple
la réélection ou plutôt l'élection de
martin schulz l'ancien président du
parlement aux pleins tout ça s'est
décidé en allemagne et non pas forcément
en france profonde
quel pouvoir vous avez dans cette
affaire là où quel pouvoir pourrait
avoir la france qui est de plus en plus
isolé mais bon il faut que la france ait
une vision est ce qui a fait l'absence
de la france au milieu du dialogue
européen c'est parfois son absence de
vision
deuxièmement il faut qu'elles
choisissent d'engager le dialogue et
vous avez raison de le dire emmanuel
macron a réussi à isoler la france de
tous ses partenaires européens parce
qu'il s'est opposé d'abord aux
britanniques avec la volonté d'un
principe très dur qui je crois dessert
aussi les intérêts des français
il s'est opposé aux grandes devises
grade à la pologne à la hongrie à
l'italie en traitant tous ses états de
lèpre nationaliste où on voulons
installer la fracture entre
progressistes et populiste et finalement
on l'a vu au dernier sommet européen
il s'est retrouvé totalement isolé même
vis-à-vis de l'allemagne qui lui a
répondu très sèchement lorsqu'il se fait
dresser merkel
quand il a exigé que ce soit simplement
six mois et par adam et dont il faut
absolument qu'on arrive à refaire de la
france un acteur de la construction
européenne est le dernier élément que je
que j'évoquerai c'est que pour que la
france soit plus forte en europe il faut
aussi qu'elle se rétablisse elle-même
pour la première fois dans l'histoire la
france va avoir le déficit public le
plus important de tous les états
européens c'est à dire que nous sommes
le pays qui tient le moins bien ses
engagements européens
comment voulez vous essaierez de
régulation vous le savez pour se révéler
mais bien sûr je n'ai une addition qui
porte sur un certain nombre incalculable
de gouvernement monsieur macron n'est
pas le seul responsable de cette
situation mais il n'empêche qu'il est le
premier à avoir placé la france au
dernier rang des pays européens là où la
plupart des pays européens se désendette
aujourd'hui nous sommes en train de
continuer à plonger dans notre propre
crise et nous
pas être crédible dans le dialogue
européen lorsque nous prétendant faire
la leçon au reste de l'europe alors que
nous mêmes nous sommes incapables de
retrouver confiance en nous et de
retrouver une véritable compétitivité
trois maires questions sur la conférence
de presse des beignets de macron parce
que c'est lié aux problèmes européens de
droite ce que vous trouvez comme
beaucoup le disent que c'est un tournoi
où ce que ça donne événement pour vous
ce qui va se passer jeudi soir mais
attendons de voir ce que dira le
président de la république ce que ce que
je regrette c'est que il est lui même
dépassé de très loin le calendrier qu'il
s'était fixé bien avant le dramatique
incendie de notre dame est
il y avait au fond déjà une forme de
grand débat qui dure indéfiniment qui
nous a empêchés pour partie d'avoir ce
ce débat européen si nécessaire moi je
sais que ce que je crois c'est qu'il
faut qu'on sorte du brouillard sur sur
la question sur les chalets les grandes
questions de la rue qui poussent le pays
à ne pas sortir du brouillard
actuellement mais la russe et quelques
milliers quelques dizaines de milliers
de personnes que que effectivement le
gouvernement n'arrive pas à contenir
nous n'arrivons pas à rétablir leur nous
sommes quand même une grande nation
jamais nous avons connu une période de
crise aussi durable aussi longue aussi
anxiogène elle aussi mais il faut c'est
également parce que les républicains
vont pouvoir aujourd'hui permettrait
justement que ça s'arrête
mais quand il ya eu les émeutes de
banlieues qui était quand même autrement
plus impressionnante par la violence et
le nombre de ceux qui y participaient je
ne me souviens pas que la france ait
versé dans cette violence rituel pendant
un si grand nombre de semaines
donc oui maintenant bien sûr il faut
agir la droite qui a contribué puisque
la droite a été la première à proposer
cette loi anti casseurs qui a été
d'abord rejeté par la majorité de
monsieur macron avant d'être
heureusement récupérés mais que de temps
perdu et surtout j'allais dire au fond
que de temps perdu pour décider on
aurait pu écouter les français plutôt
qu'en le premier ministre vient nous
dire qu'il y a un problème fiscal en
france au terme de ce grand débat on se
dit qu'on avait vraiment pas besoin de
ces longues semaines de débats de ces
millions d'euros dépensés de ses cahiers
de doléances et de ces échanges
soigneusement mis en scène pour arriver
à cette évidence oui il y a un problème
fiscal en france nous sommes le pays
champion du monde des prélèvements
obligatoires et je crois qu'au fond on
aurait pu décider plus tôt mais
organiser moins longtemps ce débat qui
n'a fait que retarder est les décisions
nécessaires quand justement sur ce sur
ces dettes cet endettement français par
exemple est ce que vous pensez à
un qu'il faut revenir totalement sur le
crâne le temps de travail ça fait partie
de ce qu'on lit dans la presse
concernant la france depuis maintenant
des années
oui ou non est ce qu'il faut à risques
c'est sur l'année sur la semaine sur les
35 heures est ce que quelle est votre
position
il faut qu'on arrive à travailler plus
mais si vous me permettez de reprendre
cette expression qui avait fait le
succès de nicolas sarkozy il faut qu'on
puisse travailler plus pour gagner plus
moi ce que je crois c'est qu'aujourd'hui
l'un des grands problèmes de la france
c'est que le travail ne paye pas assez
beaucoup de français travaillent dur et
ne s'en sortent pas et là il ya un
problème majeur dans le fait
qu'effectivement nous avons besoin de
libérer le pouvoir d'achat des français
surtout de rendre travail sa dignité de
rendre au travail
sas à sa rémunération et donc je ne
crois pas qu'on puisse sortir de cette
crise par la création d'un nouvel impôt
déguisé qui consisterait à faire
travailler les français plus longtemps
pour la même rémunération
l'idée de supprimer un jour férié pour
financer la dépendance c'est une idée
qui n'est rien d'autre en fait que la
création d'un nouvel impôt ou encore une
fois je le redis nous avons une
fiscalité qui déjà si effectivement
mettre à bas les 35 heures même s'ils
devraient facto on sait qu'on travaille
plus de 39 heures
est ce que par exemple c'est une des
idées qu'elle souvent été défendue par
la droite mais qu'elle mettrait en chaos
si les 35 heures sont un sont un totem
en réalité qui n'existe plus ce qu'est
ce qui est fait est ce qu'il faut le
remettre officiellement il faut
certainement officiellement changé notre
rapport au temps travail je pense que on
a raté avec la loi travail l'occasion
d'une réflexion de grande ampleur sur la
nature du travail en france puisqu'on
voit bien que les formes de travail les
manières de travailler se diversifie
mais fondamentalement ce qui est certain
c'est que là aussi reprenant la question
de la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires que notre famille
politique a porté
combien de temps at il fallu pour
qu'enfin on sorte de cette idéologie qui
a fait que les français ont subi cette
situation si pénible de devoir
travailler sans s'en sortir on ne on ne
sortira pas de la crise qu'ils
traversent la france si on ne revalorise
pas le travail si on ne redonne pas au
travail sa place dans notre pays
supprimez les quelques elle qu'elle
qualifie je jouais pas je vais pas
commenter des annonces qui n'ont pas été
faites mais quelle démagogie de fixer
alors que les politiques ont échoué et
je le dis là aussi sans idéologie toutes
les familles politiques ont leur part
dans la crise que nous traversons
aujourd'hui
mais quelle démagogie de transposer
l'échec d'une classe politique sur des
hauts fonctionnaires
au fond la grande question n'est pas de
savoir s'il faut supprimer les n'a
peut-être que l'ena n'est pas le
meilleur moyen pour former les hauts
fonctionnaires de demain la vraie
question c'est comment former le mieux
possible et aux fonctionnaires de demain
et c'est pas en offrant en pâture à
l'opinion une grande école qui a formé
notre autre fonction publique qu on se
sortira des problèmes d'aujourd'hui
j'ajoute que la haute fonction publique
l'aller les administrations en général
on se plaint de leurs défauts que quand
on n'a pas su leur donner un cap
moi je crois que c'est le chef qui doit
assumer sa responsabilité et le général
de gaulle où georges pompidou n'avait
pas de problème avec les énarques parce
qu'ils avaient une direction à leur
proposer on se plaint que
l'administration n'occupe le vide que
lorsque le vide laissé par des
politiques qui ne savent pas le remplir
par une vision forte à fumer qu'est ce
que vous considérez vous l'agrégé de
philosophie nalement mails pour être un
proche à ut emmanuel macron est en tous
les cas ce qui me frappe si vous voulez
la première qualité d'un d'un enseignant
et je prétends pas être un bon
enseignant mais j'ai quelques années
d'expérience en la matière la première
qualité d'un enseignant c'est de pouvoir
dire à ses élèves vers où il les conduit
et comment il va les faire avancer
est ce que je crois c'est qu'aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron laisse la france dans
une situation d'inquiétude assez
profonde parce que sur tous les sujets
qu'on évoque en ce moment on est au fond
au milieu du brouillard sur la question
du temps de travail sur la question des
retraites
quel suspense incroyable qu'on voit des
membres du gouvernement qui ne cesse de
de chaque semaine d'inventer une
nouvelle solution de proposer un nouvel
impôt il faut enfin sortir du brouillard
la france a besoin d'un cap clair elle a
besoin d'avancer et permettez-moi de le
dire au fond c'est le résultat ce débat
présidentiel que nous n'avons pas
vraiment eu parce que la présidentielle
ne s'est pas jouée sur des grands sujets
de fond et je regrette que le débat
européen soit en train d'être escamoté à
peu près de la même mais finalement d'un
point de vue de la formation il s'agit
d'emmanuel macron de voudra faire du
luxe panne ya quand même quelque chose
qui vous rapproche l'âge
vous êtes des intellectuels en tout cas
glucksmann est le fils d'un grand
intellectuel macron est un disciple de
riquet à vous est agrégé de philo qu'est
ce qui vous sépare fondamentalement vous
avez liste est justement depuis ce matin
pour tous ceux qui nous écoutent des
choses qui sont fondamentalement
différentes
mais est ce que cette différence elle
est réelle et bien sûr qu'elle est
réelle d'abord encore une fois le savez
c'est souvent le problème qui est posé
depuis maintenant très très longtemps
républicain
ont voté pendant les deux premières
années du mandat d' emmanuel macron tous
les textes emmanuel macron ce qu'est ce
qui est de l'or je crois pas que ce soit
le cas pratiquement tous les matins que
ce soit le cas il faudrait revenir dans
le détail mais si jaloux un travail ils
l'ont voté mais parce qu'au fond la loi
travail si vous laissez un peu comme sur
le plan européen la réforme de la
directive sur le travail détachées dont
le gouvernement se fait gloire
aujourd'hui ce sont des améliorations et
ce sont des améliorations marginales par
rapport à l'ampleur des grands sujets à
traiter
prenez la loi travail effectivement on a
dit qu'on allait plafonner les
indemnités prud'homales en cas de
licenciement abusif bon et bien
évidemment il y avait une insécurité
juridique mais chose est sûre les gens
qui recrutent c'est c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas neutre mais
fondamentalement quand on est devant des
sujets d'une telle ampleur quand on est
devant effectivement on en parle est un
déficit public si abyssale une dette
publique si importante quand on est
devant une crise qu'ils traversent la
france qui est si grande faune sur tous
ces grands sujets que s'est il passé
réellement
et bien pas grand chose presque rien et
bien parce que vous savez très bien que
pour gagner de l'argent dans ce domaine
terre pour récupérer pour que l'état
récupère de l'argent et désendette il va
falloir car une réforme massive des
retraites est passé à 64 65 ans et la
seule chose qui permettrait de rapporter
9 ou 10 milliards puisque le jour férié
ca ou deux même pas il va falloir
adopter un grand plan d'ensemble de
baisse des dépenses publiques ça c'est
certain
et ça ne les aurait jamais fait sa
nouvelle amie à droite
alors d'abord la droite a quand même été
plus plus plus plus allante sur le sujet
que d'autres familles politiques
deuxièmement surtout disons le ça ne
vous aura pas échappé en 2017 le projet
de la droite était un projet très
ambitieux pour réformer enfin un pays
qui avait besoin de retrouver un peu
d'oxygène et de retrouver confiance en
son avenir et c'est pas seulement la
question de la baisse de la dépense
publique c'est la question d'une école
qui puisse transmettre à tous les
enfants
la culture commune nécessaire à leur
avenir c'est la question de savoir
comment rennes 2 longueurs à faire face
aux défis migratoires on en a jamais
accordé autant de titres de séjour que
sous le mandat des manuels mâcon sur
tous ces grands sujets qui sont
fondamentaux pour que notre pays puisse
avoir un avenir et que cet avenir soit
serein et bien il faut des actions très
forte et je regrette de le dire parce
que c'est pas pour le plaisir de
l'opposition j'aurais été très heureux
que la pays saisissent l'occasion de ces
deux dernières années pour pouvoir se
réformer en profondeur mais rien n'a été
vraiment
et le travail est encore devant nous pas
vous apparaissez comme convaincu muller
et toujours cette petite voix tranquille
qui n'est pas fondamentalement la marque
de la droite de ses allées de ces 30
dernières années les chirac les pasqua
et seguin et même nicolas sarkozy
c'était les tonitruants vous vous êtes
un bon élève un élève brillant mais
c'est pas totalement le la même approche
on vous écoute une sorte de mélodies sur
l'antenne de radio classique jeu c'est
plutôt reiner leur registre ou plutôt
berlioz tout ce qu'on est en france et
pourtant valéry giscard d'estaing parle
d'un climat carrément de guerre civile
froide en france avec les violences les
manifestations plutôt les les propos
terribles contre les policiers
d'atmosphère anti riches des propos sur
les réseaux sociaux qui sont tout
proches de la haine au ps il faut qu'ils
ont c'est d'être avec vous et hommes du
rang mais permettez-moi de vie ce qu'ils
font à un bel ami mélodieux pour
remédier à tout ça je crois qu'on en vit
dans une société qui est profondément
fracturé avec des tensions très fortes
gérard collomb qui est même un ancien
ministre de l'intérieur issu de la
gauche n'ose a averti en partant de son
ministère que nous étions aujourd'hui
côte à côte et que demain nous pourrions
nous retrouver face à face je crois que
dans un moment comme celui ci on n'a pas
droit à l'inaction on n'a pas droit à la
confusion
on a une exigence de transparence et le
sérieux qui est plus grande que jamais
mais je crois que dans un moment comme
celui ci on doit aussi pouvoir faire de
la politique avec sérénité
on doit ne pas attiser les tensions et
assumer c'est vrai que c'est pas le
temps on voudrait assurer par les voix
du front national assumerait clarté mon
but n'est pas d'abord de récupérer
quelques voix que ce soit mon but c'est
de hockey puisse faire un vrai choix
mais il faut pas laisser la politique
sombrer dans une forme de marketing
électoraliste on n'est pas là pour
tenter de faire de la politique en
cherchant à capitaliser sur telle ou
telle voie ce qui compte c'est seulement
de pouvoir offrir aux français une
perspective qui leur redonne confiance
en leur avenir en prenant en charge
sérieusement tous les grands problèmes
qui sont devant nous et c'est je crois
ce qui est aussi nécessaire dans ce
débat européen
parce qu'une bonne partie de ces
problèmes suppose pour être résolu une
action européenne forte et convaincu
merci françois xavier bellamy le miti et
à caen ce soir fonds de l'europe
rétablir la france dont nous avons parlé
tout au long de cet entretien